okay so in this presentation we're going
to go over the nervous system but more
in particular we're going to study in
neurons and how electrical signals are
transmitted from cell to cell so let's
get started so when we just do a quick
overview on the nervous system you know
the nervous system is like any other
organ system it's made from a collection
of organs which are made from a
collection of tissues which are made
from a collection of cells so the
nervous system is a network of these
what's unique about the nervous system
is that it controls thoughts movements
and various life processes and though
how it does that how the nervous system
does this is through sending of signals
electrical signals to and from the brain
and that's kind of what we're gonna look
at in a little bit the nervous system
responds very quickly you know you can
try this at home you know if you just
turn all the lights on
you know you and a friend turn all the
lights on and and get real close to one
another and look into each other's eyes
and then on the count of three turn the
lights off and when you do you'll notice
that almost immediately the pupil gets
bigger that's because again the dark
light causes nerves in your eyes to
readjust and so that's a that the point
is that the nervous system responds to
change very very quickly so you think
about well what must happen in order for
this person to pick up the Apple that's
sitting on this table well it's kind of
neat light past the first reflect off of
the apple you saw the white arrow enter
and the red arrow reflect white light
enters red reflects to the person's eyes
well your eyes contain photoreceptors
called rods and cones cells that will
send an electrical signal to your brain
your brain will then receive the signal
and send a message an electrical signal
down your spine down your arm
eventually that signal will reach your
hand now the muscles in your hand will
react to that electrical signal watch
what happens you start reaching for the
Apple an event
you grab the Apple and you know you can
consume it but it's a lot of a lot of a
lot of actions of your nervous system
that goes into just picking up an object
so when we look at neurons what neurons
are are another name for nerve cells and
so here's kind of a typical drawing of a
nerve cell here the function of a nerve
cell is to transfer electrical signals
and we call these signals impulses so a
neuron is gonna send impulses electrical
signals to the brain and from the brain
those three main parts to an ER and I
just highlighted the cell body you might
also hear this called the soma som soma
and the cell body or the soma is what
contains the nucleus and all the
organelles that are fairly typical to a
eukaryotic cell notice there's little
branches coming off of the cell body
these are the branches are called
dendrites and what they're gonna do is
they're gonna receive a signal from a
neighboring cell in my animation there's
an impulse that spiked flashing yellow
object is an impulse and it's coming
down from the neuron on top well a
dendrite in the middle neuron just
received an impulse and eventually that
impulse is gonna travel down that long
straightaway called an axon so in my
animation the impulse has just traveled
down the axon is and has reached the end
of the axon and so what happens next
well we'll get into that in just a few
moments before we get into how neurons
actually send signals let's look at the
three different types of neurons the
first or what are called sensory neurons
and these are the neurons that detect
our senses they detect stimuli and they
transmit signals to and from the brain
so in our little animation here let's
say that this lady has her hand over a
very tall candle but there are sensory
neurons in her hand that will sense heat
and will send a signal to her brain
saying
pull your hand away so your sensory
neurons are related to your five senses
you know your sense of sight your sense
of smell your sense of hearing your
sense of taste your sense of touch in
your nose you have sensory neurons to
detect smell on your tongue you have
sensory it's sensory neurons to detect
the taste the second type of neuron are
what are called inter neurons and the
reason for the picture is because these
are located inside of the brain and the
purpose of the inter neurons are to
receive signals to receive the messages
from your sensory neurons so a moment
ago we saw that cartoon lady touching a
hot candle well the nerd that sensory
neurons in that woman's hand sent a
signal up to her brain
so the sensory neurons in that woman's
hand sent a signal to the inter neurons
in that woman's brain eventually she'll
pull away from the hot candle and that
brings us to the third type of neuron
called motor neuron so what is gonna
cause her to pull away from a hot candle
if you're touching a hot candle well
that's gonna be the job of your motor
neurons so in in that example from a
moment ago with the lady touching the
hot the hot candle you know her brain
will send a signal back to her hand and
that's what we see here we see a signal
going back to the woman's hand and in
our hand our muscles so the motor neuron
is gonna pass signals to other tissue in
this case the motor neuron is sending a
signal to the muscles in that woman's
hand who is just a moment ago touching
the hot candle and so we can see look at
the the far right of the motor neuron
you can see that the motor neuron is
actually connected to the muscle cells
and when the muscle cells receive that
electrical signal the muscle cells will
stretch and contract basically the woman
will pull away from the heat so these
are the three types of neurons here
well now let's focus on how a neuron
actually sends a signal so there's a
state I want to describe when a neuron
is at rest
a neuron has what's called resting
potential when it's at rest it's not in
the process of sending a message not in
the process of sending an electrical
signal and so let's zoom on into this
neuron here let's look at the cell
membrane of this neuron okay so we can
see that the top of the picture is the
exterior of the neuron and the bottom of
the picture is the interior of the
neuron well we can actually insert an
electrode a little tiny micro electrode
into the neuron to measure the strength
of the electrical charge and by doing
this we've actually discovered that the
neurons interior has a negative charge
because there's a lot of proteins that
are inside of the cytoplasm so because
of all those negatively charged proteins
that just popped up the inside of a
neuron typically has a negative charge
now
scattered amongst the negative proteins
are a few positive potassium ions
however they're just not in as much na
not in as large numbers as all the
negative potassium so because excuse me
because of the negative proteins so
because of all those a negative proteins
the internal charge is around negative
70 millivolts and when we apply the
electrode to the outside of the neuron
we discover that the exterior the
outside has a positive charge well
that's because there's an abundance of
sodium ions and so that causes the
exterior the outside of the neuron to
have a positive charge so when we look
at the full picture here's what we see
exterior positive charge because of the
sodium's interior negative charge
because of all the proteins however
there are a few positive potassium
scattered about those positive potassium
Tsar actually going to be really
important
so now we're I want to have a discuss an
action potential when a neuron is
actually sending a signal and an analogy
I like to make is that an action
potential is kind of like people at a
sporting event doing the wave
so here's people doing the wave at a
sporting event one person stands up and
then the men sits down and then the
process repeats and so an action
potential is kind of like the people
doing the wave at a sporting event and I
hope you'll understand the analogy once
we go through it
so let's actually show you now how a
neuron generates an impulse in the
picture we see sodium positive charged
sodium on the outside positively charged
potassium on the inside I just did not
draw the negatively charged proteins in
this picture because I didn't want to
include too much clutter in the picture
but please remember the inside of a cell
the inside of a neuron has a negative
charge so when an impulse occurs around
negative 40 millivolts those black that
black set of doors on the left
that's a sodium channel that black
sodium channel is gonna open and when
that happens the positive sodium is
going to diffuse from a high
concentration to a low and go into the
cell that that influx of sodium is going
to bring the charge from negative 40 all
the way up to positive 50 millivolts
that's the impulse an impulse is that
change from negative to positive charge
that's what the impulse is and so what
happens next now that the internal
charge is positive 50 well after that
happens around positive 50 notice how
the black sodium doors on the Left
closed but around positive 50 the red
doors the red potassium doors are gonna
open the potassium channels are gonna
open and that's gonna allow potassium to
diffuse from a high concentration and
exit the cell that's gonna drop the
charge all the way down the negative 90
so the
urghhh went from negative to positive
back to negative at negative 90 that red
doorway that red set of doors that red
potassium channel is gonna close and and
now again the area inside is back to
being a negative charge this process is
simply going to continue down the axon
down the length of the neuron let's take
a closer look at this so let's look at
this in a little more detail here's a
couple neurons in close proximity to
each other and I'm gonna have the neuron
on the Left send an impulse down its
axon
well let's freeze the impulse and let's
actually zoom in for a closer look and
when we do we see a bunch of positive
sodium on the outside a bunch of
positive potassium on the inside it
might look like the inside is positive
because of all the potassium remind
yourself the inside actually has a
negative charge because of a lot of
negative proteins that are inside the
cell
I just didn't draw the negative proteins
because I didn't want to put too much
clutter but remind yourself the internal
charge is negative so when we now look
at an action potential at negative 40
millivolts the black sodium doors are
gonna open that's gonna cause a bunch of
sodium to diffuse into the cell bringing
the charge from negative 40 all the way
up to positive 50 at positive 50 those
black sodium channels are going to
respond and close but by the way that
positive 50 right there that's the
impulse and impulses that change from
negative 40 to positive 50 so at
positive 50 like I just said those black
sodium channels are going to close and
the next set of doors on the right that
red set of doors on the right those are
potassium channels at positive 50 the
potassium channels are gonna open and
then a bunch of potassium is gonna exit
and diffuse out of the cell that's gonna
drop the charge from positive 50 all the
way down the negative 90 and so when it
hits negative 90 when it hits negative
that red set of doors that's currently
open those potassium channels are gonna
close and then then we'd simply just
repeat the in bucket in the middle the
middle set of black sodium channels are
gonna open that's gonna cause sodium to
rush on and that's gonna might make the
charge spike and come all the way up to
positive 50 and that will simply repeat
what we said a moment ago at positive 50
that middle black set of sodium channels
are gonna close and the middle red set
of potassium channels are gonna open and
then potassium is gonna exit dropping
the charge from positive 50 all the way
down to negative 90 this is what an
action potential this is what an impulse
is it's the change from negative to
positive and negative to positive and so
when the charge drops all the way down
to negative 90 that middle set of red
potassium channels is gonna close and
look on the right
on the right you have a set of black
sodium channels that are gonna open and
so at negative 90 the black sodium jet
the Sant channels open and the sodium
rushes on into the cell and that brings
the charge all the way back up to
positive 50 and same thing happens at
positive 50 the black sodium channels
are gonna close the red potassium
channels are gonna open and then the
potassium will simply diffuse out of the
cell that's how an impulse moves that's
how an action potential moves down the
length of a cell and so here's a real
neat animation that shows the entire
thing sodium comes in brings the charge
the positive potassium exits sodium
comes in brings the charge the positive
potassium exits and it goes back to
normal
sodium comes in the charge of his
positive potassium exits the charge goes
back to negative so there's a real neat
animation and at a faster speed right
there well you might be thinking
eventually you're gonna have a bunch of
sodium on the inside that doesn't belong
on
inside that should be on the outside a
bunch of potassium on the outside that
doesn't belong on the outside but should
be on the inside there has to be a way
to clean up this mess
so who cleans up the mess there's a pump
called the sodium potassium pump is
gonna clean up this mess and how it's
gonna clean up the mess is through a
type of cell transport called active
transport with the use of ATP adenosine
triphosphate and so what happens sodium
is gonna be pumped back out of the cell
watching my animation one two and even
three three sodium ions at a time will
go into the sodium potassium pump and
with the help of ATP when that third
phosphate is broken off heat is released
that heat causes the sodium potassium
pump to change shapes and therefore
release the sodium to the outside of the
cell well what happens next is two
potassium one two potassium will will go
into the sodium potassium pump and the
pump will change shapes back to its
original shape and then release the
potassium back to the inside of the cell
so when does this happen when does the
sodium potassium pump clean up the mess
well after the impulse is passed where
is the sodium potassium pump located
it's located in the cell membrane and
why does this mess need to be cleaned up
in order to restore the cell back to
normal this way another impulse can be
sent in the near future so if we look at
this animation I've now added the blue
sodium potassium pumps I didn't add them
in add them before because it would have
been too much clutter before but we can
see that three sodium's at a time are
pumped out I didn't show ATP but I just
wanted to get the idea what the sodium
potassium pump is and two potassium is
at a time are pumped in so you can see
the cell is resetting itself at the
bottom one three three sodium's are
released and two potassium are brought
back in so there's
six sodium potassium pumps in my
animation imagine if all six of them
were going right now at the same time
the cell would be restored in a fairly
quick fad fairly quick amounted and so
here we are back at our animation that
we saw well let's continue moving the
impulse down the length of the axon
eventually the impulse reaches the end
well let's zoom out in and take a closer
look at this when we do here's what we
see we see a little gap in between the
neuron on the left and the neuron on the
right that gap is called a synapse so
the definition of a synapse is the gap
between two neurons we have a neuron on
the Left gap and then neuron on the
right so as we saw a moment ago sodium
comes in creates an impulse and
potassium exits and so this process
continues down the length we saw I'm
just kind of reviewing from a moment ago
sodium comes in potassium comes out
sodium comes in potassium potassium
would come out but wait now here we've
come to our problem that that impulse
has reached the end it's caught it's
reached what's called the terminal end
there's nowhere else it can go that
impulse cannot cross the synapse onto
the next cell so that's a problem the
solution are in the are in those those
bubbles those three circular shaped
bubbles called vesicles vesicles hold
proteins called neurotransmitters that
are going to be sent from in this case
the cell on the left to the cell on the
right so what happened we just saw step
number one an impulse has reached the
end what is called the axon terminal
step two neurotransmitters are going to
be released from the neuron on the left
watch this
so that vesicle is holding three black
dots that vesicle will fuse with the
actual cell membrane and begin to
release those three black dots those
three black dots are the
neurotransmitter proteins and you can
see how one of them just landed on a
Recep
to the cell on the right once the cell
on the right captured once a receptor on
the cell on the right captures as some
neurotransmitters that's gonna trigger
the openings that's gonna trigger the
opening of the first sodium channel
notice how the black sodium channel just
opened sodium rushes in creates an
impulse potassium exits the same process
happens sodium rushes in creates an
impulse and potassium exits notice how
the impulse started all over again to
the cell on the right okay so now I
really am just reviewing because I just
copy and pasted this from earlier so now
as we're following that new impulse like
we saw a moment ago around negative 40
millivolts the black sodium channels are
gonna open sodium is gonna rush on and
that's gonna bring the charge all the
way up to positive 50 that's the impulse
at positive 50 the black sodium channels
will close the red potassium channels
were open and potassium will exit the
cell drop in the charge all the way down
the negative 90 at negative 90 that open
set of red so red potassium channels
will close and in the middle that black
set of sodium channels will open once
that happened the sodium rushes in
brings the charge all the way up to
positive 50 that's the impulse at
positive 50 that open set of black
sodium channels are gonna close and in
the middle that red set of potassium
channels are gonna open and that's gonna
cause potassium to exit drop in the
charge all the way down to negative 90
millivolts at negative 90 millivolts
that open set of red potassium channels
are gonna close and the next set of
black sodium channels are gonna open
cause and sodium to diffuse on and bring
in the charge all the way up to positive
50 millivolts you can see we're just
repeating ourselves at positive 50
millivolts the black
sodium channels closed the red potassium
channels
then potassium exits and the impulse
again the internal charge again drops
all the way down to negative 90
millivolts and the process continues the
process continues of course until the
impulse reaches this location the
synapse again so remind ourselves that
the impulse is going to reach the
terminal end so sodium comes in there's
the impulse potassium exits that's gonna
cause the next sodium channel but open
sodium comes in creates an impulse and
then the potassium will exit that's
going to cause the next sodium channel
the open sodium comes on in creates an
impulse and so the term the the impulse
is now reached the terminal end so the
neurotransmitters are going to be
released across that gap across that
synapse so there goes a vesicle it fuses
with the cell membrane and slowly is
taken into the cell membrane and
releases the black dots the
neurotransmitters notice how one of the
neurotransmitters landed on a receptor
to the cell on the right that's gonna
trigger the opening of a sodium channel
which will then allow sodium to diffuse
on in create an impulse and then
potassium will exit that's gonna cause
the next sodium channel to open sodium
comes on in creates an impulse and then
the potassium will exit so you can see
we really are just repeating ourselves
and you know when we look at this let's
say you wanted to do something like kick
a soccer ball let's say you're looking
at a stop at a soccer ball you're
staring at it your brain gets the e you
get the idea to kick so your brain is
gonna tell muscles in your foot to reach
back and kick well how does that work
watch this your brain is gonna send an
electrical impulse down cell number one
at the end of cell number one
neurotransmitters will be released cell
number two will create a new impulse the
impulse will travel down cell number two
at the end of cell number two that
impulse will trigger the release of more
neurotransmitters cell number three
we'll catch the neurotransmitters and
create its own impulse the impulse will
travel down cell number three
eventually the impulse reaches the end
of cell number three and the impulse
triggers the releasing of more
neurotransmitters cell number four
catches the neurotransmitters creates
its own impulse the impulse travels down
the length of cell number four and
eventually the impulse gets the bottom
of cell number four that impulse will
trigger the release of neurotransmitters
which land on cell number five saw
number five creates its own impulse the
impulse moves down the length of the
neuron ultimately then the impulse is
gonna reach the muscle cells in your
feet remember if you're trying to kick a
soccer ball you're sending a signal down
to your foot so eventually here is the
impulse it's finally reached the muscles
of your foot that impulse will actually
cause muscle cells to move that's what
causes you to kick or to pick up
something or to just get out of bed if
you want to just get out of bed your
muscles are reacting to electrical
signals sent from your brain by the way
remember the name of the neuron in the
picture we talked about it earlier it's
called a motor neuron so there you have
it I hope you understand why I chose my
animation now of people doing the wave
and action potentials kind of like
people doing the wave if you're in my
biology class pause this video
bring me your answers on a separate
sheet of paper I'd love to check them
for accuracy so pause the video try to
answer these good luck